Yeah. Hello.
>> You're a Muslim?
>> Yeah, I'm Muslim. I'm black, too.
>> You're a black Muslim?
>> Yeah, I'm black, too.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Shamsu, can you hear Shamzu?
>> Yeah, I'm listening. I'm listening to
you guys. Can I ask you questions?
>> Okay. So, would you follow a religion
with corrupted scripture?
>> No, definitely not.
>> All right. How many sets of scriptures
did your God reveal
>> before the Quran?
>> Three before the Quran.
>> Three before the Quran. Cool. What
happened to them?
>> They got corrupted.
>> Cool. So you do follow religion with
corrupted scripture.
>> No, we dropped those three corrupt
corrupted scriptures. They're not part
of our law
>> because those three scriptures were
what?
>> Corrupted.
>> And they were whose scriptures?
>> Our scriptures. But they
>> So your script
>> Yeah. But we don't use them anymore.
>> I can't, bro. So in your religion,
you do have corrupted scriptures. We had
>> the scriptures. We don't anymore.
>> So, so ask
>> the reason why you don't have this.
Wait, wait. I forgot what I asked him.
He was
>> about about about Muhammad in the NGO.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, so,
okay, fine. So, you don't have them
anymore, right? Since since you dropped
them, you don't have them anymore,
right?
>> Yes.
>> All right, cool. So I just asked the
last guest, where can you find Muhammad
in the angil? In the Quran 7 verse uh
says you can find Muhammad in the Torah
and in the So where do we go?
>> I'm not exactly I don't really study the
Injil or the Torah or any of them. I
only study the Quran because we dropped
those other three. We don't use them
anymore. So we just I just learn the
Quran personally. Cool. So, cool. So,
you don't you don't use them. All right.
So, do you think that just because the
books are corrupted and you say you
don't use them that that removes the
fact that majority of your religious
scriptures in your religion were
corrupted? So, how many scriptures in
your religion were corrupted then?
>> 43.
>> So, the majority of your scriptures that
have been revealed in your religion have
been corrupted. But it's not really
something that's inevitable. Not all
like because it's not really that it was
corrupted. Not people didn't really
people didn't really memorize it as much
as the Quran. So as time went on
>> No, we're not we're not dealing we're
not dealing with Okay. The story around
what happened and why it wasn't
memorized and all that. That's
irrelevant.
>> Yeah.
>> You got to be honest. The majority if
the majority of the scriptures revealed
in your religion were corrupted, you
follow a religion where majority of his
scriptures were corrupted. So you are
the one that follows a religion with
corrupted scriptures. That's that's
that's literally just simple logic, bro.
You can't say, "Oh, well, well, we you
know, we put them aside so we no longer
have a religion with corrupted
scriptures." You do. It doesn't work
like that, bro.
>> But right. Yeah. Y'all are not supposed
to debate. Most of the guys you're
debating right now. Yeah. They're
minors. You're supposed to go debate the
other Muslim scholars like um SQ Mink
and the rest. Most of
>> Are you Are you not Are you Are you able
to engage or are you going to bring up
other people?
>> No, I'm just going to go right now cuz I
got to attend to. But yeah.
>> All right, man. So, uh leave Islam, bro,
because Islam is untrustworthy. Majority
of his scriptures are corrupted. Bro, I
don't know how you trust a religion full
of corrupted scriptures. That's that's
crazy.
>> I think I'm cool with Islam. But y
>> So you like you like a religion full of
corrupted scriptures? You cool with
that?
>> Not really. But the I don't study the
corrupted scriptures. I only study the
Quran.
>> Well, you can't study the corrupted
scriptures because they corrupted. Why
would you want to study corrupted
scriptures? That don't mean that that
doesn't mean that you're that doesn't
mean that this is not involved in your
religion. The reason why you don't study
them is because they corrupted. That's
your fault. That's that's just what you
got in your religion, bro.
>> But the Quran is not part of the
corrupted scripture. It's the only one.
>> No, the Quran is part of the problem.
>> It's really not. I don't mind you um
debating Muslims, right? But I just ask
one major question,
>> man. Bro, I love when the logic clicks
and they just they just don't care.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. I know.
>> Hello. Official. I see the topic.
official. All jokes aside, no
description. No. Islam not corrupted.
>> That wasn't the topic.
>> Yes.
>> Would you trust a religion with
corrupted
>> description? Untrustworthy. Islam is
more than trustworthy.
>> Can you hear us?
>> I trust my religion. It's not corrupted.
>> Yeah, I can hear you. I trust the
religion. It's not corrupt.
>> Why are you talking?
>> I can hear you. Can you hear me?
>> I think you might have a delay.
>> You asked me a question and I answered
it.
>> I dealt with him last night. Look,
>> you
>> Does he have a delay on his side?
>> You asked me a question, I answered I
said, "Yeah, I wouldn't I think I got a
delay." One second. One sec. Can you
hear me?
>> You have a delay. You might You might
want to reload. Like reload.
>> One second. Let me just check. One
second, guys. One sec.
>> Yeah, there's a delay.
>> Yeah. One second. One second.
>> Reset your app and your connection and
then try to come back later. Woo! Man,
>> somebody said Brandon said Allah one and
four. He putting up Shaq numbers.
>> Would you put Shaq at the free throw if
it's if it's if it's for the game for
the series? Absolutely not. Shaq
trustworthy at the free throw line if he
one and four. If he one for four, man,
would you trust him?
>> According to the according to the
Muslims, he is. They put Shaq at the
line every time.
>> Every time, man.
>> They only trust.
>> They They only tr they only trust that
one free throw he made.
>> That one Hey, Shaq made it once, so he
trustworthy, man. We could trust him
every time he go to the line. He good.
>> The mother the mother three free throws
he shot, he he didn't shoot anymore.
Hey, they going to see they going to see
Kobe and Shaq and they going to see the
stats.
Kobe 90 Kobe 96% accuracy. Shaq 4%
accuracy. The Muslim going to go with
Shaq.
>> Going to go with Shaq.
>> Come on Shaq. Peace be upon him. Come on
Shaq.
>> Come on Shaq. What we doing Shaq? What
sh What are we doing Shaq? Only fear
one. You a Muslim?
>> Yeah, I'm Muslim. How are you guys
doing?
>> We're good. How are you?
>> Good.
>> Good man.
>> So, Islam is untrustworthy. Like what
are your facts? Like come up with what
do you
>> Well, we have this simple
>> we have this simple logic that we that
we follow. It starts like this.
>> Would you trust a religion contain with
that has corrupted scripture?
>> No.
>> Neither will we. Now, the Torah, the
Psalms, and the Gospel, these are books
that Allah revealed, right?
>> Yep. Now, are they preserved or were
they corrupted?
>> Did you just say uh Psalms?
>> Psalms. The Zabor.
>> I I don't know about that one.
>> Zabor. The Zabor.
>> I don't know about that one. But yeah,
the rest. Yeah, I agree with you.
>> Okay. So,
>> the book of
>> Got you. So, these books that Allah
Allah revealed these books and these
books got corrupted. Is that right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, Islam is a religion that's
full of corrupted scripture. Now, the
Quran, Allah reveal the Quran. The Quran
is intact. It hasn't been corrupted yet,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that means that the Torah, you
said you don't know about the Psalms, so
we'll we'll scratch out the Psalms, but
the Torah, the and the Gospel have been
these are Allah's books that that got
corrupted. These are Islamic scriptures
that got corrupted. That means that
Islam majority of its scriptures got
corrupted and is therefore
untrustworthy.
>> Okay. Now, you made that statement, but
let me tell you why. I I agree with you
on the corrupted ones. The Quran, it
says in the Quran that it's indeed our
message and we will preserve it. And
it's talking about the Quran. It's not
talking about uh like uh the Bible. It's
not talking about um what do you call
again or whatever you talking about.
It's not talking about the Injil. It's
not talking about uh Yeah. It's not
talking about all those. It's talking
about the Quran. And there's a reason
for that. The Quran is only for the
people of our time. It's for the people
after the time of Jesus. The people were
the time of for Muhammad. It's
Muhammad's people. It's not like the
injil was for the time of uh Jesus Isa
for his people.
>> Yeah.
>> So if it's corrupted, even if it's
corrupted, it doesn't like serve a but
we believe in it, but it doesn't serve a
purpose. We don't follow upon it, but we
believe in it.
>> Yeah. But you're it's still in the
religion that it has corrupted
scripture, right?
>> It's Yeah, it's corrupted. Yeah.
>> So that means that Islam is
untrustworthy because it has corrupted
scriptures in it.
>> And you said that you wouldn't follow a
religion with corrupted scripture. But
right now you're justifying why you do.
You're justifying why you follow a
religion with corrupted scripture, which
is something you said you wouldn't do.
>> Okay. So that but I don't follow those
scriptures. I follow the Quran though.
>> Yeah. But Quran is different.
>> Yeah. You follow Islam and you don't
follow the other books that got
corrupted. You follow the Quran now. But
that doesn't change the fact that you're
following a you're following a religion
that has corrupted scriptures in it and
therefore is untrustworthy.
>> Okay. So could you say the same for the
Bible though?
>> No, the Bible is not
>> because you using that against me, then
the Bible's corrupted then. Oh, that's
that's that's what you you believe that
the Bible is the Torah gospel and Psalms
that Allah revealed originally and then
they got corrupted.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> They got corrupted all over time.
>> All right. So, if the Bible's corrupted
and so these are the scriptures of Allah
that got corrupted. These are Islamic
books, Islamic scriptures that got
corrupted. That doesn't change the fact
that you're following a religion that
has corrupted scripture. majority of its
scriptures got corrupted and so
therefore it's not trustworthy.
>> Okay. So you said Islam, right? You know
Islam means submission to God. But
there's a there's a different religion.
Muslim. Muslim is different than Islam.
Do you understand that? And Muslim came
later. It came later for the Quran.
>> What what does that have to do with the
fact that you follow a religion that is
untrustworthy because it has corrupted
scriptures? Because Muslim wasn't a
thing when Jesus was alive. Basically,
when Moses was alive wasn't a thing.
>> Just to be clear, you're saying that
Jesus and Moses were not Muslim.
>> They were not Muslim, but they submit.
Muslim is just the people for Muhammad.
Muslim is but Islam is submission to
Allah. They were
>> That's the best thing you said all day,
man. That Jesus and Mo and and Moses
were not Muslim. I appreciate that.
That's good. That's actually That's
true. That's the truth.
>> That's the truth. So, you're one step
closer now. I need you to deal with this
though that I don't think you're
understanding the weight of what you
admitted to. You admitted that you would
not follow a religion that has corrupted
scripture. You also admitted that Islam
has corrupted scriptures.
>> Yeah.
>> And yet you're still following it. So
why why don't you stop following Islam?
>> I follow the Quran, bro.
>> Yeah. You like
>> Yeah. You follow Islam that has
corrupted scriptures?
>> Yeah. But you understand that it says in
the Quran and we believe that the Quran
is the word of God. It says that those
scriptures were corrupted over time.
>> So if those scriptures are corrupted
then Islam is not Allah is not
trustworthy.
>> I was okay. So explain to me how that
like explain how do you come up with
that?
>> So for example, let's say that you have
a babysitter, right? Who got assigned to
four to four children. Okay. The first
child, the first child, she lost. The
second child she didn't feed. The third
child got hurt and ended up in the
hospital. But she never promised. She
never said, "You know what? I'm going to
do a great job of watching these kids."
>> But this last kid, this fourth kid, I'm
going to make sure I do a good job at
watching this kid. And this with this
fourth kid, she actually does a good job
of watching him. He doesn't get hurt. He
gets fed and he's safe. But the other
three kids, she lost, didn't feed them,
and they ended up getting hurt. Would
you say that this babysitter is
trustworthy?
>> Yes. But let me let me tell you why. Not
the babysitter. Not the babysitter. I
know what you're using that for. You're
trying to say that God he Muhammad's
Quran, his uh basically his like uh
book. He But what I'm trying to tell you
is though, think about it like this
though, okay? If if Allah is trying to
get us to believe in Islam and he's
trying to get us to believe him and like
he's trying to get us to uh like become
Muslims.
>> Mhm.
>> Why would he preserve a different
religion from a different time because
it's like
>> well well think of it like this. If if
uh if he wanted to convince the Jews and
the Christians that Muhammad was a
prophet
>> Yeah.
Then he would make sure that the Quran
and what Muhammad is coming with is in
line with what they have already. So
they wouldn't have any reason to reject
Muhammad. It's all supposed to be
>> the Bible's corrupt.
>> So if the Bible's corrupted, then the
Jews and Christians have no reason to
believe Muhammad's a prophet. Why do
they What's the Bible's corrupted?
>> No, I don't want you to tell me why it's
corrupt.
>> You want me to say why the Bible is
corrupted?
>> No, I don't want you to tell me why it's
corrupt. I want I I want you to
>> No worries. I want you to deal with the
fact that Allah is not trustworthy
because he let one of his kids get hurt,
lost another kid, and didn't feed
another, but only protected and
preserved one of the kids. So all
>> your god killed his own kid. So what do
you what do you what do you say to that?
How was your god his his son and killed
his own son? How was that?
>> It's been activated. I didn't I didn't
even have to snap my finger for it to
activate in you, did I?
>> Well, you said
you said, "Oh, your god did this. He let
his get hurt while your god has what do
you call again?"
>> I don't think I go ahead and watch the
clip back, man. Just go and go on and
reflect.
>> Activated, man. It's been activated.
>> It's been activated. Full
talk about Islam. Soon as they realize
what what actually their religion
teaches, as soon as they realize it's a
problem, that's when it activates and
they go fool. That's it. You can't get
them to it's over with. Can't reset.
>> Only thing they do is factory reset the
activation period. You know what I'm
saying? So, you know, like you they
don't go back to normal.
>> They just factory reset as a robot. as a
robot.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> Full Muslim factory reset it back into
full Muslim. But it's from from 0.1.
That's it. It to go from 0.1
>> then it build up then factory reset back
to 0.1. He never going back to a full
human. He got to go off the live sleep.
Wake up tomorrow.
>> He got He got Hey, it ain't no that
don't just go away.
>> That don't just go away. You got to
sleep that off.
>> You got to sleep that full Muslim off,
man. That ain't going away, man.
>> That's tough.
>> You going to have to sleep that one off,
man.
>> This is too fun. Um, Quran over Bible. I
like that. I like that. I like that.
Quran over Bible.
>> Hello.
>> Hello there. How you doing?
>> You're not. Are you okay?
>> I'm sorry.
>> Are you okay?
>> Am I from the UK?
>> Are you good? No. Are you good? Are you
good?
>> Am I good? Yes. Yes. Yeah. How about
yourself?
>> Yeah. No, I thought I have I have a go
at your um Islamic dilemma.
>> Awesome.
>> Try to understand it. Okay. So um so
what's the question? So what's the
question again?
>> Would you trust a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> Okay. No.
>> Are the Torah, Gospel, and Psalms and
Quran all revelations from Allah?
>> Yes.
>> Were any of those corrupted?
>> Then Islam is untrustworthy. It has
corrupted scripture.
>> No. I'll tell you why. I'll tell you
why. Cuz what we believe as Muslims is
this world is a test and God allows
humans to sin to make mistakes. So the
ones who corrupted the books scriptures
are the humans not God.
>> No worries. So Allah allowed human
beings to corrupt his scriptures and so
therefore you have corrupted scripture
within Islam and therefore Islam is
untrustworthy like you said. So why do
you why do you follow a religion that
has corrupted scripture?
>> As I said before, life is a test and God
tests people. So it was the humans who
corrupted the scripture, not God.
>> You you don't have to repeat that. That
doesn't change the fact that these
scriptures are corrupted, right?
>> So why did God sacrifice his son on the
cross? Why? Why? So
>> it activated, didn't it? It activated.
It straight up.
>> I'm not training Christian. Why?
>> Straight up activated.
>> I I I don't know if I've seen it that
quickly before.
>> Okay. But that's the whole point. Um if
if humans sin, why did God have to his
son for
>> Are you okay, dude? What do you mean?
>> He don't even know what's happening.
That's the That's the crazy part. Now
watch this Quran. What's happening right
now?
>> It's your tricky question. That's the
problem.
>> What's the
>> Are you understanding?
>> What's the conversation about right now?
>> It's about the scriptures. But you said
you said humans don't allow humans can't
sin. They can't make mistakes, but they
can. Don't you get that?
>> Who who who said that, Mr. Quran? Who
who said that? I said that. That's what
Islam is.
>> You
>> There's no way. He You just said You
just said we said it.
>> Hey,
>> wait. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> No. You You got You got to go. You got
to go.
>> No, bro.
>> You got to go.
>> He just said He just said we said it.
>> And he said,
>> then you said, "Who is that?" And he
said, "I said what?" Bro, I don't know
what that was. That was a day. Hey, the
dude said the Quran, what did he say?
The previous scriptures called a virus.
So
>> heated with a virus.
>> He activated with a virus.
>> Activated. He got activated and then
caught a virus immediately. Bro,
>> peace be upon you, man. Peace be upon
you.
>> Peace be upon you as well from our Lord
Jesus, man. How are you?
>> Good.
>> I'm going to make this simple. Okay. I'm
going to make this simple. I'm going to
leave. Okay.
>> Would you would you follow a religion
with corrupted scripture
>> according to you? Not let's not talk
about this one thing I'm going to say
and I'm going to leave. Would you follow
a religion with corrupted scripture that
everyone's dying to know this, my
brother?
>> No, I wouldn't.
>> Okay.
Was the Torah, Gospel, and Psalms, and
and Quran revealed by Allah?
>> Yes, they were.
>> Were any of those books corrupted?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, Islam has corrupted scriptures, and
you follow Islam?
>> We follow the Quran. We don't follow
those scriptures.
>> Do you follow? Do you follow Islam?
>> It's for Wait, it's for different
generation. is not for is not for you
know what I mean or not.
>> I got you. But do you follow do you
follow the do you follow the religion of
Islam?
>> Yes sir.
>> So you follow a religion that has
corrupted scriptures within it and is
therefore untrustworthy.
>> Is the Quran uncorrupted?
>> Sure.
>> It's not. But let me make this work with
God. I want to say something.
>> So the Quran is good but the other
scriptures are not good. So you follow a
religion that has corrupted.
>> Wait wait wait. Because God the Almighty
give you guys the desire desire to
change and change this message and you
guys did so.
>> So So Allah gave them
>> our problems. So Allah wanted so Allah
wanted the scriptures to be corrupted.
>> He gave you the desire to
>> so Allah wanted so Allah wanted the
scriptures to be corrupt.
>> Same way when he gave the desire to Adam
to eat the apple of the
>> So is this a yes. Is this a yes? Allah
wanted the scriptures to be corrupted or
a no.
>> No. No.
>> So if he didn't want the scriptures to
be corrupted,
>> if he didn't want to do so,
>> bro, I ain't going to lie. This this
it's this that the it's that hour, man.
This is that hour, bro. Muslim man.